(drums playing)
- Welcome to Fiesta Latina presentation
of Movimiento Cultural.
My name is Kevin Diaz, executive director,
and founder of Movimiento
Cultural Afro-Continental.
We are a New Haven-based Cultural Group
dedicated to promoting
and preserving Bomba,
which is part of our traditional
Afro-Puerto Rican heritage.
It is with great joy that we bring to you.
Our virtual presentation
of Bomba music and dance
sponsored by the Yale Peabody Museum,
and it's annual Fiesta Latina.
I have been involved in
promoting and preserving
Afro-Latina culture in New
Haven, for the last 25 years.
And I am proud of how much we've grown
and elevated our cultural heritage.
I hope you enjoy this history of Bomba
and I encourage you to
dance and sing with us.
Bomba!
- Bomba is both a traditional dance
and in musical style from Puerto Rico,
it's origins are rooted
in the Island's history
of African slavery.
Today, it has evolved
into community expression
and celebration of
Afro-Puerto Rican culture.
The music has its roots in West Africa,
a region from which slaves were captured
and brought to the Island.
Many believe that the Bomba
was created in Puerto Rico
in the 1600s,
the Bomba thrived where
West African slaves
and their descendants lived and worked,
which was mostly in colonial plantations,
along the islands coast.
Whenever a dancer enters
the Bateo dance circle,
the dancer improvises while the drama
follows his or her steps.
(shekere shaking)
(singing in foreign language)
(drums)
- Today, Bomba can be
heard throughout the Island
and the mainland United States.
It is recognized as a
primary form of expression
of Afro-Puerto Rican culture.
It's also known as the music of resistance
in the rallies and social
justice protests of today,
you will often find
Bomba drummers, singers,
and dancers performing.
Did you know that Bomba
music has been around
in New Haven since the early 1970s?
The first fiestas, De
Louie saldia festivals,
which featured the Bomba were
held on the New Haven Green.
They were later relocated
to the Hill neighborhood
and became an annual event.
And I'm proud add that the
leadership and participation
of strong, fierce, and fearless
Afro-Puerto Rican women
is one of its distinctive features.
(singing in foreign language)
(drums snaring)
(shekere rattling)
In the Bomba, there are
over 20 rhythmic variations.
The most commonly known in play today
are the Sica, Cuembe, Yuba,
Holande and the Seis Corrido.
Some rhythms are more commonly heard
in some parts of the Island than others.
Seis Corrido for example,
it's a rhythm commonly heard
in the town of Loisa.
(drums blaring)
(singing in foreign language)
Let's take a look at
the Bomba instruments.
First, the Bomba drums,
which are called Barriles,
tambores or buleadores.
They keep the basic rhythm
while only one drum called
primo or subidor, improvisers
while following the dancer.
Two other instruments
also help keep the rhythm,
including the Cue, which are two sticks
that hit a wooden barrel
or the drum and one Maraca,
which is usually in the
hands of the singer.
(singing in foreign language)
(shekere rattling)
(drums blaring)
(choir ululating)
- [All] Bomba!
- That was awesome.
- We hope you've enjoyed
learning about the Puerto
Rican Bomba and its history.
We hope our fellow (speaking
in foreign language) out there,
feel proud of their African heritage,
and we encourage you to join us
as we continue to celebrate the Bomba.
For more information
about Movimiento Cultural,
go to www.movimientoculturalct.org.
See you at the next Pombaso, Bomba!
(drums playing)